cette communauté parfois
marginalisée et le système
de santé.
Camille Feireisen.
Se faire vacciner en plein air
et aux sons d'un pow-wow
traditionnel.
De quoi rendre moins nerveuse
Alycia.
Je suis anxieuse, mais en
arrivant ici le fait de voir
des gens danser, chanter c'est
merveilleux on se sent comme
à la maison.
Mission réussie pour
cette clinique de vaccination
éphémère.
STEVE TEEKENS, directeur général
de Na Me Res
Ici on offre une sécurité
culturelle, dit-il. Ce qui
signifie créer un endroit où
les gens se sentent chez eux
Il existe encore des biais
dangereux à l'égard
des Autochtones au sein
du système de santé, selon lui.
- Je connais des personnes
qui ont demandé des soins
médicaux et l'une des premières
choses que certains médecins
leur demandaient était s'ils
étaient ivres ou avaient
consommé de la drogue?
Ils étaient juste malades,
dit-il.
Ici, les membres des Premières
Nations, les Métis et Inuits
de Toronto ont pu recevoir
première ou deuxième de dose
du vaccin Pfizer, dès 12 ans
ou plus.
Le tout prodigué par
des prestataires de la santé
issus de leurs communautés.
Sensibiliser les Autochtones
à la vaccination dans des
grandes villes comme Toronto
n'est toutefois pas facile,
notamment parce que la
population est dispersée.
"Nous sommes plus de 95-mille
Autochtones à Toronto", dit-elle
et malheureusement nous
subissons encore souvent
un traitement différent lorsque
nous allons à l'hôpital.
L'autre problème, ajoute
la médecin, c'est que bien
souvent ces communautés sont
touchées de manière
disproportionnée par la pauvreté
et la précarité.
- "Ça n'a pourtant pas été
évident de faire avancer la
vaccination des Autochtones dans
les villes", rappelle
le député. La province ayant
d'abord prioriser
les communautés éloignées.
Pour les Miller, de la Première
Nation des Chippewas de Rama,
c'était en tout cas une sortie
en famille réussie.
- Rachel se dit heureuse d'avoir
vécu cette expérience, d'autant
qu'à l'école son enseignant
les sensibilise en ce moment
à la culture autochtone.
Mais, surtout, elle a hâte
de pouvoir enfin bientôt serrer
ses grands-parents dans
ses bras.
Ici Camille Feireisen,
Radio-Canada, T